[Music]
Varanasi India stretching along the
sacred Ganges
it is Hinduism's holiest city millions
of pilgrims come to bathe in the
purifying waters but others come for far
different purpose they come here to burn
the dead out in the open in public Fein
thiol has a job that many might find
appalling Fein belongs to a unique
Indian caste or community known as the
domes it is the traditional role of the
domes to cremate the Hindu dead members
of fiends family have been burning
corpses for hundreds perhaps thousands
of years for devout Hindus touching a
corpse is highly taboo it is a ritually
polluting act those who work with the
dead are considered unclean and
therefore untouchable they are outcasts
but the domes also play a pivotal role
in the Hindu approach to death which is
based on the idea of reincarnation
Hindus believe every human soul passes
through many lives the ultimate goal is
to unite with the Supreme Being but
until they are worthy they continue to
be reborn the holy city of Varanasi
provides a kind of spiritual shortcut
Hindus believe that if they die here and
their ashes are scattered in the Ganges
their souls are liberated from the cycle
the domes work as a team while some
build pyres and oversee cremation others
scavenge among the ashes and coals
whatever touches the dead is theirs to
keep
[Music]
body we have to burn usually has golden
jewelry on it
these have sinned taken the women have
no strings
the men have changed in fingerings we
take the gold and silver off the body
the bodies continue to burn all through
the night spending the night with the
dead might seem of a frightening task we
get habituated to it and don't get
scared whether we are here or on the
other side of the river we can stay
alone in the cremation grounds and they
don't get scared the fires continue into
mourning as more bodies are brought down
to the river King takes up his post
again and immediately begins building a
funeral pyre his first customers have
arrived the family of the deceased
gathers around as Dean works it is the
traditional role of the firstborn son to
set fire to the body but first he must
shave his head and dress in white robes
féin leads this firstborn son to the
sacred flame and then leads the man
threw the punch Okuma the ritual of
circling the body five times
they set fire to the corpse burning
bodies as thines only means of survival
he lives a Hindu paradox the only way
for him to escape the death industry is
to die and to be reborn into a higher
caste for now the fires will continue to
burn and in the city of death life goes
on